salan richard gott tan mom so Chris
Wilding who works for us dressed up as a
12 year old kid with Ebola virus hmm
and we told Tim um he was from an
organization we made up called Sick Kids
Foundation and me if you see Chris he
does not look like he's 12 I mean it's
all from it we never thought this would
work we told tan mom the sick kid was
here to meet Nicole Kidman but Nicole's
canceled at the last minute so we told
Tam mom to pretend she was Nicole Kidman
and he agreed so Sal sat down the whole
staff explained the situation in tan mom
and she is a sweet woman to do it but
Sal told time on that because Nicole's
from Australia she'd have to speak in
Australian accent make it realistic
let the fun begin you're familiar with
Nicole Kidman right yeah I've heard her
she was married to Tom Cruise oh that
one yeah
what's his name Timmy right yeah he's
like 12 or 13
I'm not Nicole came in lying you're
supposed to be Nicole yeah well he
doesn't know that he has the Ebola virus
we she couldn't come in your report you
okay just for the kids sake yeah
now Nicole Kidman is Australian could
you do a North American accent how about
that one let's rehearse it
oh hi Nicole I'm so happy you're here my
name is Timmy hello Timmy
Callie Oh Jimmy it's me Nicole Kidman
it's me Nicole Kidman what's his name
Jamie you know your name no I'm Nicole
Kidman
I'm Nicole Kidman chap how are you doing
today
I had a horrible marriage two word come
to hello she just opens her mouth more
damn on once you do a little more
Australian for us Oh put another shrimp
on the barbie man I'm all right here's
what happened they wheeled in
twelve-year-old little Timmy played by
Chris
Timmy and tan Nicole Kidman hit it off
right away
how you doing today I'm so excited to
meet you
this is a special day for me you
remember my Nicole Kidman
I'm Nicole Kidman I came to visit you
because I heard you were not feeling
good years I have been your biggest Oh
everything for me and I hope to hand you
my love and my prayers with you every
day stay strong for yourself
she wasn't even nervous she's gonna get
a bowl oh no you don't know what I have
I don't even think Nicole Kidman goes
around saying I'm Nicole Kidman the
accents they go from everywhere from
Irish hello there I'm Nicole Kidman hi
top of the mornin how do you like being
a movie star Oh me so love it Timmy
asked very specific questions about
Nicole Kidman thankfully tan Nicole
Kidman was brilliant and tamam is a
master improviser so lucky for us what
was it like working on Days of Thunder
with Tom Cruise what Tom cookie was the
most wonderful movie I watched Ed's fade
and did with Tom Cruise for you did you
prepare for the role I prepared with my
manager and we rehearsed and rehearsed
every day for this special moment to
share with you what you have how many
kids I have multiple kids
10:24 take what are their names
Oh Stephen yeah Natasha
okay Freddie boom boom got it then the
list goes on and on on and on she must
have multiple teats bum bum bum bum how
would you like some tea and
it's oh my god SOTA mom's understanding
of the Australian culture is pretty
murky as evidence doesn't we go on you
want more Robin sure yeah okay
here's her murky understanding of life
over there what was it like growing up
as a young girl in Australia as a young
girl very very hot yeah lack of hunger
lot of I was hit by a car and that's how
I became a captain yes what like what's
my favorite Australian sayings Oh put a
shrimp on the donkey
Bobby we like Bobby she was hit by a car
became a captain what is she talking to
them what are you not following hair I
was hit by a car how many children do
you have a multiple about 10:30 you want
to hear talking to a little Timmy about
being married to Keith Urban sure all
right what's like being married to Keith
Urban um it's a wonderful wonderful big
big just excitement tons of excitement
I'm like he's a great singer eat sings
Oh Oh unbelievable
what's your favorite song um I love the
one he sings it's like he's saying it at
the the Grammys last year about like
being free as a bird Oh being free it
bug yes what's your favorite song Oh
mine just same one you sing it to me I'd
love to hear your beautiful voice
la la la la la a lot we went to work
free advertising Marie
he have giant shlong love sing then
things got really weird
at one point tan nicole kidman agreed to
give Timmy her blood and agreed to sleep
with him oh boy and I'll donate some
blood tail to get better just hang in
there oh wait
well you promise me one thing yeah you
just feel that forever I'll give you
some blood now you could go get some
rest and smile because it was a pleasure
meeting you
I see you big favor a shot I've never
been in bed with a lady
oh I was sleep with you okay
yes yes because you're gonna be around
forever I'll sleep with you
oh my you're beautiful oh oh
vibrant and glowing and damp thank you
so much hospital it's an accent if
someone's squeezing your cheeks together
your face that's what you saw tonight at
hospital you want steak sauce mustard
sauce and of course we did tell tan mom
later that little Timmy was not really
dying and he still banged him